right e
um
M what did you sense you you want to
observe and assess what you're trying to
do
okay I was getting pushed back on my
heels a lot you're getting pushed back
on the heels okay and what did you guys
what can you tell me about
her her
performance feels uh like a over car
okay on both hands on both hands y okay
so let's look at something so stand
up and uh you'll help me okay you'll
come on my sorry Chris and so a a body a
mass is coming forward towards me okay
uh so Here Comes This mass and if it has
more y than me then I will move to what
I call relative Yin so you made me Yin
okay um if I can get more young aspect
it will go relativ in okay so if you and
I stop him he's going to come in and we
just push him okay here he goes and we
do it together
we end up making him go that
way he ended up going that way okay does
that make sense well the takeaway here
is that you can depending on the size of
the UK the intention of the UK the
strength of the
UK um you can
become uh ex you you can generate an
exteral Superior y aspect and he will
get displaced okay so um meaning like
I'm here and I go like
that I can generate
his
displacement that means that
displacement is not actually what we're
after in the same way that positional
Integrity of the static drills is not
actually what we're after you can
maintain positional Integrity without
doing what we're
doing so you have to
understand that um the dill s the reason
I call them cultivation Fields is that
they don't really work the way that most
of our modern ego tripartite
driven understanding sees the world okay
so the way they work is I task
myself with he has his he has his young
aspect okay
and if I don't task myself with
positional Integrity I don't set up the
Dilemma like the fork in the road well
which one are you going to do a
external making a relative Yin of
him or are you going to uh bounce off
bounce him off internally do you do you
understand that the the positional
Integrity is not the goal but the
positional Integrity sets up the problem
okay and then I have to do one or the
other the fact that I can
do the other one I'm not supposed to is
what sets up the
cultivation um that I'm doing the one
that I want okay so for
example uh if I if I'm over here and I'm
working on my uh site index for my
handgun draw
okay if if I don't have a
Target then wherever I draw my gun is
good to go the target
itself is what helps set up the site
index that I want to train okay I can't
train my sight index
without the
target I can work on a draw stroke and
my grip in a very similar drill let me
let me show you I can
work on grip stance trigger press I can
work on all of that
stuff but I will not work on
my natural sight
index without that Target there
the
target is making sure that I'm in one
place and one place only on my body over
here I could work I could move my grip
over here to my left that's not where my
sight index line is and I could work on
my trigger press but I'm not working on
my sight index line the target is
helping me work on the site index line
every time and when I make
it just a point Point as opposed to a
whole
Target then that's what I'm working on
if I use the whole Target it almost
becomes like having no target okay and
it's not necessarily that I'm working on
accuracy cuz I'm just working on that
sight index line if I if I develop my
sight index line accuracy is the
consequence of it I don't I don't want
to be over here and aim my gun that's
not com that effective I want to bring
and learn how to bring the gun to the
sight index line every single time so
just by staring at that little black
piece of tape bring the gun up the dot
is right on the black piece of tape okay
so I'm not
aiming per se in that training that
looks like
aiming same thing goes
here I'm not trying to just make him go
backwards that's not what I'm trying to
do but by set setting up the elements of
the drill I set up the
crisis internal or external okay and
this is why I say it's not
important that he goes backwards it's
how are you making him go backwards okay
so as you'll see on the
video you're trying
to just get an
external displacement of him
and as you said you got pushed back on
your heels there was even one rep where
you didn't establish relative y to him
and you got relative Yin okay so you
have to make sure that this is going
in to your body and not just that you're
trying to push him okay so likewise
yesterday's video when we came here in
all likelihood if you did an external
yield is because you had to and if you
had to you're probably doing an external
push there
okay if you can SE on
contact you can do an an internal push
so again I deviate and this is probably
this external displacement over a
totally inferior
mechanical uh output that just can't do
it he's he's off balance and I move
inside his uh shaku angle you're going
to be able to push him but instead
there's a
seizure and uh that's different it looks
different the movement's different it
feels different and there's no chance of
me ever becoming uh relative y to him
it's just the more he comes in the more
it's internalized the more he's going to
go out so that's the how that we're
after not what happens to him how did I
make him Traverse the sagittal plane on
the map that's what we're doing okay all
right